is it reasonable to consider abiogenesis
as a science I know it's an aggressive
question and assumptions are being
challenged but the assumptions that life
start that people start with who study
this which don't seem to be falsifiable
nor is there any experimentation showing
life to non-life to life transition and
I think the study of the origin of life
is a fascinating field to me and I touch
on it in the book and um I'm like very
interested in continuing to learn and
write about it there is an unanswerable
question which researchers in the field
agree is not what they are pursuing and
not something that will ever be answered
which is the historical question of how
life began on Earth
we don't have a time machine We're Not
Gonna Know It
um I mean in terms of all the Sci-Fi
that I speak for yourself speak for
yourself all right if you're working on
it that's cool but like there's even
there's an episode of Star Trek the Next
Generation where Q brings Picard back to
the moment where he's like right there
in that pool and I'm like oh I wish we
could do that
um so no one is really thinking that
they're going going to say this is how
it happened there are some researchers
who are working on being able to say
this is how it plausibly could have
happened we don't even have the answer
to that then there are researchers who
are working on this is how life in
general arises in general
um trying to abstract from Earth's
chemistry and look at what life
fundamentally is what is the distinction
between when matter is ruled by the laws
of physics and when something else kicks
in
um one of the big challenges to that is
that we don't have a theoretical
understanding of what life is I talk in
the book and people often ask me about
like we don't have a definition for life
and it's true we don't but that's not
because we haven't found it yet it's
because life isn't the sort of thing for
which definitions are useful and this is
drawing on the work of philosopher of
science Carol Cleland physicist Sarah
Walker I don't want to make it seem like
I figured this out myself
um Sarah's been a guest and Sarah's been
on the show and so is Lee Cronin and
they're both mentioned in that exactly
yeah and so um Cleland points out that
definitions are useful for understanding
what words mean but they don't tell us
fundamentally what like how the universe
works so I don't need to know what
l-i-f-e means just like saying gravity
is the force that holds me to the Earth
doesn't tell me anything about how the
universe works it doesn't help me
understand anything scientifically and
so a definition for life isn't going to
actually help and that's why the
definition project there's always
something is included that you like oh
my definition accidentally includes fire
or excludes mules because definitions
are not useful here but we don't have a
theory of life and it's questionable
whether we can work towards one with
only one example
um Sarah and Lee are working on
developing a theory of life that
um off the idea that what's fundamental
about life is complexity and the ability
to store information sort of to have a
memory that persists through time but
Cleland says that you just can't do it
from one example you have to get too
abstract you're not actually drawing
from specific evidence and so we have to
go about the search for life and the
study of the origin of life differently
by sort of not trying to be too
constrained by definitions but being
sort of open-minded looking for
anomalies things that are sort of maybe
lifelike and then we dig in deeper there
so it is a tricky field in that we don't
have a clear framework yet and we're
sort of trying to find that framework
and find evidence to build that
framework from and find evidence to
support the framework that we don't
totally have yet that we're sort of
trying to design the house and build the
house and measure the house all at the
same time